at Vanderbilt the racial hate hoax took
place in the less distant past the
national headlines said that there was a
racial hate crime consisting of a bag of
excrement discovered on the footsteps of
the black Cultural Center on campus a
black student group called hidden doors
quickly denounced the unsavory bag as a
vile act they claimed quote the
violation of a place that in many ways
is the sole home for black students is
deplorable Vanderbilt in 2015 had
security cameras all over the campus
when the University Police checked the
security camera footage to investigate
the alleged hate crime they discovered
that no such crime had occurred at all a
blind student had used a baggie to clean
up after her guide dog then because she
was not aware of where all the trash
cans were on campus she left it on a a
stoop and decided not to bring the bag
with her into the building